like going back to lifestyle in
university i remember had the most
unhealthy lifestyle you could possibly
oh yeah
like i i i shouldn't a human body
shouldn't be able to do that many
all-nighters
yeah and somehow i'm i had a diet that
just consisted of mostly red bull how
many how many red bulls did you drink a
day and coffee
i would um i would drink at least at
least three cans of red bull a day yeah
and like two cups of coffee yes yeah
that sounds about right but like on
on like some all nighters when i had an
assignment that was never
ever done until the night before i had
to put in my assignment because who the
[ __ ] actually does
and it does assignment sweeps before
remember one one
one night i had i think it was like 10
cans of red bull
something like heart rate must have been
like yeah oh no it was it was insane
and don't do this do do not do this this
is a cautionary tale
and the deadline was at 8am and i
finished it at 7am
and i remember i remember thinking yes i
can finally submit it
so i submitted it and i laid down my bed
and i could not stop shaking
i just i was just like
i remember that was the exact moment
that i remember thinking man i need to
sort my [ __ ] life out
like i'm gonna die yeah dude because i i
hit like [ __ ] and i was drinking like
10 red not terrible i was like at least
like three monster energies a day
yeah on top of coffee and then also
eating like domino's pizza like two
times a week oh yeah
i kind of had a similar story where like
a lot of the times like because i wasn't
living in the the dorms
yeah yeah i would just sleep over at the
yeah in the room that i was like working
on
right so like i remember like i had like
a programming assignment i had to do
yeah and it was of course it was a
teamwork job right and
that never goes well in uni there's
always that one [ __ ] who never appears
to any of the [ __ ] assignments
and i was just like and it was just like
me and like a friend and we're just
waiting for this third person we're like
where the [ __ ] is he he's like the best
of programming he's like we can't we
can't do it just with the two of us
of course the dude never showed up so
it's just like yeah great
well if the thing's due in like what
three hours it's like five in the
morning right now
let's just store the dominoes so he just
[ __ ] called up the dominoes
we ought to like [ __ ] like seven
pizzas or something we're just like hey
everybody if you're if you're at the uni
right now just come to this room
just order like seven dominoes just come
in here we'll just eat dominoes
and the next morning i remember the
professor came in and it's just like
seven empty boxes of pizzas and there's
like eight of us just
like all sprawled out of the crowd with
pizza hangovers
and uh yeah that was the best story i
have obviously not as
interesting as a poop story but uh
where's
i mean we definitely all smelt like [ __ ]
the next day but that's about it
i'm sure i have like way more stories i
can think of but like i just
cut like none of them were coming to me
right away yeah but i just forget a lot
of them
dude i didn't realize that like i got
like super chubby during
university i know ghana's like connor
you never look chubby but dude
connor connor swears to me that he was
chubby when i first met him and i just
have completely blanked out this memory
of
mood and put this image on screen this
was like two years ago
though i look back at old photos right
how about you and i'm like man this
boy's face is around right
like i never thought i was chubby right
no but i didn't think yeah
at the time yeah i think cause it was
just the way i'm built like i don't look
that choppy right
but i remember like like a year ago like
i saw
like an image like someone's taking a
photo of me and it was like from the
side
yeah i just saw like my stomach like
hanging over a little bit and i'm like
what the [ __ ] when did that happen yeah
and you're like what
and then you'll then you start realizing
oh [ __ ] i'm chubby like i'm actually
chubby
it's so weird because i had such [ __ ]
diet and just like lifestyle choices
but i was so [ __ ] like you you guys
like when you first met me i was [ __ ]
emaciated
you were so scared everybody everybody
always says that i was so [ __ ] you're
so
skinny to put in comparison right like
all throughout high school
i haven't really like grown in height
since high school yeah i'm hovering
around like 180 centimeters
a little under six foot in high school i
think i never broke 60 kilograms
jesus christ what are you now then i am
75 now oh [ __ ]
yeah i get a lot chunked up yeah
and i was just going ham and i didn't
realize that oh
metabolism is a thing yeah yeah i i
realized that during university
obviously i'd been going
taking advantage of my body weight oh
yeah yeah
then pretty much last year i just went
ham on myself and like just cut out
everything kind of
energy drinks went gym like five days a
week and lost like 10 kilograms
yeah because i remember back then i
didn't know if i had a bigger tolerance
in alcohol or caffeine
but it always it was all like i was
drinking equally much of both
equally destroying my body with as much
[ __ ] that i was eating yesterday
yeah i was probably eating in food alone
like 3 000 calories
probably consuming like 2 000 calories
at least an alcohol
and that's not even like the monster
energy drinks that were probably like a
thousand calories plus all that
so i was going like ham on my body
because you know when you're like 19
you're like yeah bro
i don't gain weight i've never been
thinking yeah i'm not coming down i mean
that's the thing and like i had like an
insane
diet when i was in high school yeah yeah
as well and it's not just like the [ __ ]
i was eating but just
how much of it i was eating yeah like
lunch like lunch
you know like high school lunches for
like a lot of people is like you know
maybe like a sandwich or you know
like a hot dog maybe or something like
that dude i used to have
10 slices of bread i do i could do that
and just like devour that before the
noon here
i was just like i just got to school i'm
feeling a little bit hungry i'll just
eat like three sandwiches
and i and i was still skinny as [ __ ]
people like how like
jealous how how violent are your shits
because that's the only way you're
getting rid of it i think it's that
asian blood man because i've
consistently
like i've been about the same weights my
entire adult life i'm jealous yeah so
jealous
well i don't know i think my body just
when i eat when i
like start getting away my body just
shuts off and it's just like i don't
want any food
i like i'm just never hungry so it's i
don't know it's never been
a big [ __ ] superpower i mean i'm okay
with it now because i went from
dangerously skinny to just normal weight
yeah but obviously people have like
stuck around on my channel and have seen
me in that like emaciated state i just
like joey's going really fat i'm like no
i just went back to normal
that's all that happened i'm not fat we
all know youtube comments like to
nitpicks
yeah exactly